next question today David as far as the
2020 Democratic primary campaign goes
our Democrats better off going hard left
or appealing to moderates for the
purpose of ultimately defeating Trump in
2020 excellent question and the answer
to me
is so clear that I don't want to
equivocate in any way appealing to
moderates has never been a good strategy
and it has never demonstrably worked at
the national level now we can separate
this out from particular districts or
even state Senate seats Senate seats
which are the voting public is an entire
state is what I'm trying to say it's the
wrong approach to even be thinking in
these terms though and that's what
really scares me
Democrats shouldn't calculate should we
go hard left
or should we deliberately go to the
middle in order to defeat Donald Trump
in 2020 or for whatever particular
reason Democrats and people who are
voting in democratic primaries and
people who are voting in general should
vote for who they want to vote for on
the basis of how those individuals line
up with their beliefs and it's perfectly
reason to think about how those
individuals would fare in a national
campaign who can avoid mistakes who can
handle gaffes who can deal with attack
opposition research those are the
questions that need to be asked not
let's calculate where on the political
spectrum we want to pick someone with
the idea of bringing in as many
moderates and center rightists as
possible who might be disaffected by
Donald Trump or whoever is the
Republican that we are running against
pick the person that you believe is best
suited for a national campaign and whose
politics aligned with yours make that
person the nominee and then they can run
against Trump and the question is not to
calculate who's going to do better
against Trump based on are they Center
or Center left or far further left the
the question is who is it that actually
represents the views of Americans and
what we know from every
poll that fairly asks Americans about
their political positions we know that
Americans are well to the left of the
elected officials that are representing
us when you fairly go to people and say
do you think that the government has a
basic duty to provide a sort of starter
at least a starter level of care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
overwhelmingly two-thirds to 80% of
Americans depend on depending on the
poll say yeah I think that's something
that should happen now when you
politicize it in the way that it gets
politicized do you want the government
taking over health care in a socialist
manner of course people start to say oh
no I don't want that but on the issues
when asked fairly income inequality
health care net neutrality whatever the
country has moved to the left and our
politicians have not so the question is
not let's calculate left center middle
Center left or whatever let's go through
the primary process supporting the
people whose views reflect our views
let's see who avoid mistakes and who can
deal with the gaffes and the stumbles
and people will start to emerge as
leaders and we will see whether they are
going to be able to handle the attacks
that no doubt they will be presented
with if they are the Democratic nominee
so the calculation that we need to make
is not one of what will moderates and
disaffected Republicans like now let's
put aside for a second that I believe
this is the wrong question altogether
the idea of running to the center has
never worked okay there's this idea that
if we as Democrats progressives leftists
whatever pick someone that is closer to
the center we will pick up centrists and
will win because someone will run
numbers and say you know if we get just
three additional percentage points of
the independent vote Republicans can't
win or whatever at the national level
this just haven't worked okay I would
argue that save for conservative
districts Democrats running to the
center is a disastrous strategy there
are House elect elections okay where we
make the calculation and we say okay
what kind of democrat can win in
Virginia that's a different type of
Democrat than the Democrat that can win
in coastal California or in
Massachusetts for example but the
primary process already sorts that out
nationally this ultimately comes down to
personality communicating ideas well
staving off attacks from the other side
and avoiding scandals so we might as
well just put somebody in whose politics
match those of the leftist voters that
are making the decision here and of
Americans more broadly and those have
moved to the left as I mentioned on just
about every issue taxing the rich to pay
for things I mentioned health care
already seriously dealing with climate
change campaign finance staying out of
places that aren't our business around
the world pick the person that appeals
to you on policy and likability which we
know for the Democratic primary voters
is someone that is further left of
center than many of the people that we
often hear suggested as we've got to run
to the middle to bring people from the
other side over it hasn't worked it's
not a defensible strategy let's stop
pretending that it is